I mean I really think the nation state
is not relevant anymore in a digital age
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we are talking with Jeffrey Tucker
he is the proprietor of Liberty dot me a
new gated community of libertarian
participants Jeff thanks talking yes sir
liberty and me how long has it been up
and what does it do we've only been up
80 days now so or maybe closer to 90 now
the traffic is soaring that's just great
you mentioned gated community but that's
only part of it right so it's got a
public aspect and a private aspect the
public aspect is massive publishing and
tons of free content the content is
provided by members actually and it's
the quality has been exceptionally high
and they're writing about everything
that's exciting of it up you know I used
to be an editor now I realize in
retrospect I was part of the problem
allowing this sort of spontaneous order
within Liberty me everyone has his own
his or her own sort of private space due
to technology you can now have an
infinite number of subdomains so myself
domains tuckered out Liberty that me and
every member cuz their own sub domain
and then you can decide kind of what you
publish or what you what you make public
what they do and i am not the gatekeeper
anymore they just post what they want
and the quality has just gone through
the roof I you know I realized this
actually in retrospect a lot of times
writers write for the editor rather than
for the consumer and so in our space
they're writing directly for the
consumer talk to about the the gated
part then because you do it's about nine
dollars a month of you on full
participation and what what what happens
behind the paywall yeah okay so what i
did i put into one single spaced every
form of communication you can possibly
ever imagine so we've got a private
messaging which is really nice because
we're not part of the federal dragnet
right a system so i like it for that
reason i know the NSA watches by gmail
and I but no they watch my facebook
Messenger within Liberty me now I have
private messaging with people we have
ongoing chat 24-7 so you can get on
there and have friends from all over the
world right and you get unlimited book
downloads we're uploading new books yeah
talk about the i'm in the library and
resources that you have they're both in
terms of books and kind of classic texts
of liberty of the Liberty movement but
then
also you have questions being answered
by you know what kind of sluggers row a
libertarian yeah well I mean in the last
80 days we've had 65 different
professors teaching nightly classes in a
live classroom setting so you know every
single night and learn about whatever is
going on that right it could be Bitcoin
it could be migration issues or firearms
training we've actually had a much
bigger mess of that are you gotta
feeling the NSA is why what's fun i was
able to actually get a firearms training
online you know sitting for my best hope
I never would have been and I don't have
like the teachers and like I could
everybody point your gun outside and
shoot it well he did it's I'm homework
which is funny and the next time we went
back for classes that everyone do your
homework and I was kind of like well I
didn't really but I feel like I know
more that I did so and then you have one
of the things that you advertised on the
site is that it's no trolling this is a
kind of it's awesome yeah talk about you
know here's the thing when you have skin
in the game you actually care about the
value of the community and that makes it
very different from these public spaces
like like Facebook or Twitter we have
all these wars I i I'm not really into
that stuff you know I really wanted a
space where I I don't care about people
having homogeneous views on things maybe
they don't have to agree with love
argument and differences of opinion of
course you got to have that but what
matters is if people have an investment
and the value of the community then it
changes the outlook people are much
nicer to each other at how many how many
participants do you have in what are you
shoot where we're going we're on we're
approaching the 4k around but I really
want to get to 10k certainly by the end
of year and I would you know we've got
scalability now in this world thanks to
virtualization we can be a hundred or
you know 400 whenever whatever we're
talk talk a little bit about how I mean
you you've been a long time literary
movement activists and whatnot you I
think exemplify a kind of optimistic
forward-looking screw the government
yeah mentality which I find very
appealing you know yeah the government
exists it gets bigger it gets better etc
but basically your message seems to be
you know lets you know you keep an eye
on it but don't let it determine your
options in life where where to send come
here's the thing
I mean we are so fortunate in this
generation to have access to tools that
our forebears didn't have we have the
digital cloud that's a place where we
can migrate and it's a place of a zone
of freedom that unleashes human
creativity I think this is what's
happening we're seeing the ground shift
in the ER thought feat I mean I really
think the nation said is not relevant
anymore in a digital age where do you
see the kind of future clouds between oh
kind of rumbles ya mean being in you
know there's a virtual cloud and if
freedom up here but then we are in
meatspace and you know that's kind of
but it's it's if they can slow us down
and they always do and they always have
you know but but really the progress of
humanity has always come down to
migration and communication to me those
are the two key things people moved away
from feudalism to the city so they could
talk exchange ideas and get to know each
other and have better communication with
people then they migrated from the old
world to the new world to get away from
despotism so those and then they hear
again they moved out of the countryside
into the cities so they can have more
communication so these kind of forces of
history this desire for better
communication peer to peer relationships
and as an realm of freedom of the
driving force of progress for all of
history and the point is that right now
in the 21st century we can actually do
this we can both migrate and communicate
on a global level leaving aside our
assigned roles as members of a citizen
of a nation-state you know that was a
20th century thing I just don't think
it's going to be relevant or and vulture
we will leave it there the website or
the community site is actually Liberty
dot me they have been talking with jeff
tucker Jeff thanks for speak thanks so
much for having me for reason TV I'm
Nicholas me
you